a
[Música]
[Aplausos]
creo intensamente en que no se cuida lo
que no se ama y no se ama lo que no se
conoce frase célebre dicha por
rabíndranath tagore poeta bengalí y
premio nobel de la literatura pero que
tan cierto es esto en los últimos años
se ha hecho evidente la creciente de la
conciencia de la humanidad para proteger
al planeta y eso se puede haber
reflejado en parte por las cientos y
miles de organizaciones alrededor del
mundo que luchan para proteger los
bosques las selvas las aves el jaguar
pero qué pasaría si lo que hay que
conservar es el objeto de tus más
profundos miedos como cuidamos algo que
nos da asco cómo proteger algo que no
nos gusta y este es el caso de los
anfibios y reptiles y me refiero a las
ranas a los sapos a las salamandras las
lagartijas las culebras las víboras
alguna vez se han puesto a pensar porque
les tenemos tanto miedo
y es que hay mucha gente que les aterra
y a veces ni siquiera sabemos por qué
pero para entender esto hay que analizar
algunas cuestiones y perspectivas
históricas por ejemplo a muchos de
nosotros nos dijeron desde pequeñitos
que las serpientes sean animales
malévolas pero astutos y nos contaron
aquella historia donde a través de una
trampa que nos tendieron fueron
condenados a arrastrarse por el resto de
la eternidad los sapos por ejemplo bueno
no a mucha gente les gusta por allá de
1833 un bellísimo bellísimo sapo fue
bautizado como horribilis por un solo
gol pero nada lo único al que no le
gustaban personajes como carlos linneo
que es el padre de la sistemática
natural le desagradaban en gran manera
los sapos y las ranas a tal grado que
los describió en uno de sus documentos
más importantes como incitó animales
asquerosos y repugnantes de piel sucia y
aspecto fiero o personajes de la
literatura de la literatura como
shakespeare los designó como los
desagradables ingredientes
calderón de las brujas lo podemos
recordar con un fragmento de magnet
hierba y cuestas en la cazuela rueda de
víbora ojo de lagartija pie de rana
pero esto no siempre fue así no siempre
fueron las terribles criaturas odiadas
por la humanidad
inclusive en la mayoría en prácticamente
todas las culturas de la historia está
la serpiente como una figura positiva y
sin irnos lejos kukulcán que es
representado por una víbora de cascabel
es el hacedor supremo del universo o en
otras representaciones como la cultura
azteca está el exalto battle o la
coatlicue los anfibios no se quedan
atrás para las culturas por ejemplo
orientales son sinónimos de dinero y
prosperidad para muchas otras significan
principalmente la fertilidad actualmente
a quienes la hay quienes creen que sus
cantos anuncian las lluvias porque son
mensajeros directos de los dioses del
agua
a veces y sin saberlo esos animales son
parte esencial de nuestra cultura pero
esta perspectiva lamentablemente ya
cambio
actualmente hay registradas
aproximadamente unas siete mil 800
especies de anfibios y más de 9.500
especies de reptiles en todo el mundo
son animales super importantes para
nosotros por ejemplo nos están dando
grandes avances en biomedicina como es
el caso del ajolote mexicano que además
de ser una especie emblemática de méxico
tiene la capacidad de regenerar sus
miembros lo que la ha convertido en una
de las salamandras más estudiadas en el
mundo y cuyas propiedades pueden
conducir investigaciones a sanar
lesiones del cerebro y de la médula
espinal oa curar enfermedades del
corazón y del hígado o por ejemplo las
serpientes su veneno es estudiado para
la generación de nuevos analgésicos o
incluso para tratar el cáncer además son
pieza clave del ecosistema son base para
la cadena trófica porque ellos alimentan
a muchas especies de animales y se
alimentan
yo soy herpetólogo quiere decir que
trabajo con sapos y culebras
y quiero decir confesar que para mí al
ser muy relevante todo esto pues yo no
entendía cómo era posible que no
existiera una materia sobre anfibios y
reptiles porque no existen programas de
conservación porque a la gente y tiene
tanto desinterés y a la vez tanto miedo
así que me pregunte qué caso tiene
dedicarse a estudiarlos para
conservarlos y al final llegará alguien
y nos va a matar porque no les gusta o
porque les tiene miedo
pero bien dicen que hay que ocuparse de
lo que nos preocupa así que con un
compañero en la universidad fundamos una
organización que se dedica a promover la
conservación de los anfibios y reptiles
en yucatán y gran parte de nuestro
trabajo es luchar para romper todos
estos paradigmas y todos estos temores
que tenemos sin siquiera saber por qué
sobre los anfibios y reptiles
pero no hay que ser biólogo ni
herpetólogo ni fundar una organización
para hacer algo a veces simplemente hay
que interesarse y dejar de ver a estos
animales como lo que no son porque no
son ni feos ni asquerosos muy por el
contrario yo les puedo decir que me ha
tocado besar a un sapo y no se convirtió
en un chip o en un príncipe se convirtió
en un rey
pero hay que hacer algo ya la
conservación es responsabilidad de todos
nosotros y me refiero a todos
pero no podemos estarnos a mañana porque
tal vez mañana ya sea demasiado tarde la
declinación de las especies de anfibios
y reptiles es indiscutiblemente real y
catastrófica a una escala planetaria
sólo para mencionar algunas causas
existen las especies invasoras que han
acabado con anfibios en todo
centroamérica la contaminación como el
uso de pesticidas y plaguicidas que han
eliminado poblaciones completas de
salamandras en el estado de mexico
enfermedades o parásitos como el hongo
quítrido que diezma las poblaciones de
anfibios y salamandras en todo el
planeta la explotación intensiva que se
traduce en la extracción de cientos y
miles de ejemplares anualmente para
consumo y recreación o el cambio
climático global que ha llevado a la
extinción de especies en todos los
continentes
pero es que si no nos interesa no hay
modo de hacer algo imagínense es algo
así como una loca tratando de convencer
a la gente de que no todas las
serpientes son venenosas y peligrosas ni
son malas y que los sapos no te quieren
hacer pipí en los ojos y no te van a
dejar ciegos
pero que al final parece no interesarle
a nadie
estoy segurísima de que todo el mundo
está familiarizada con la frase de que
el amor es ciego pero yo les quiero
decir que no siempre es así yo les
garantizo que si abrimos los ojos y nos
quitamos los prejuicios podríamos ver y
admirar sus formas sus tamaños sus
colores y seguramente nos vamos a llegar
a enamorar de ellos
quiero compartirles ya para terminar una
breve experiencia personal en uno de
nuestros eventos un día llegó un padre
con su pequeña hija y estaban
aterrorizados por la idea de tocar a una
serpiente sobre todo la niña tiene un
pavor en la cara el papá siempre hagan
agarrándola por el hombro hasta que él
ya no pudo más la soltó retrocedió y
dijo ya no puedo con esto y se volteó en
ese momento la niña aprovechó y tocó
suavemente la colita de la serpiente que
sujetaba mos muy cuidadosamente delante
de ella en ese momento el rostro de la
niña se reconfiguró y entre brincos y
risas porque se había dado cuenta de que
había vencido a su miedo volteó a ver a
su papá que estaba impactado por el
cambio de actitud de su hija y lo jaló y
le dijo mira papá que si yo puedo tú
igual
y el papá se acercó y pasó exactamente
lo mismo
bueno el papá obviamente que no dio de
saltos pero ocurrió la misma magia
el papá se hacer con nosotros y nos
confesó como movido por el miedo había
matado a cualquier serpiente que se le
atravesaba y también nos dijo que ese
suceso le cambió el paradigma se dio
cuenta de que no sólo le estaba
enseñando a su hija las cosas al revés
sino que si efectivamente animales
maravillosos a ellos lo seguimos viendo
a nuestros eventos y siempre llevan a
alguien nuevo a la mamá a la hermanita
al tío al amigo al primo transmitiendo
el amor cambiando percepciones en pro a
la conservación de sus organismos y les
dejó con el mismo pensamiento no se
cuida lo que no se ama y no se ama lo
que no se conoce gracias
increíble ponencia pamela gracias
entonces desde chiquita encontrabas a
los sapitos lindos sí que justamente
hace unos días mi mamá me decía qué
curioso que siempre ha coleccionado
ranitas no recuerdo cuándo fue la
primera vez que vi una rana real pero sí
cada vez que la agarro esta sensación de
haití que bonita está
excelente pamela y pues yo me llegó la
reflexión de ella pues en mi casa no
mataran
yo creo que muchas veces me da mucho
asco un fuerte aplauso para familia
muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]